madame la Présidente je veux nier être
objectif ni faire de la philosophie je
veux simplement me rappeler de ma
jeunesse ou dans les années 70-80 on
nous expliquait qu'après l'année 2000
nous mangerions tous des cachets ou des
cachets je crois et que le
l'alimentation ne saurait plus un
plaisir
depuis 2000 il me semble que c'est
exactement l'inverse qui est arrivé
c'est à dire que ce qu'on nous avait
promis 30 ans à verre avant était juste
l'inverse de ce qui s'est passé depuis
2000 le consommateur français et les
consommateurs sur la planète qui voit
l'agriculture et l'alimentation
française comme étant la plus
gastronomique du monde ont été sur les
circuits courts ont voulu des AOP ont
voulu une traçabilité des produits ont
voulu du bien manger et ont voulu sans
cesse des injonctions à l'agriculture
qui a essayé au fur et à mesure de ce
temps là de répondre à leurs exigences
et bien je vous le dis tout net sans
objectif je suis contre la viande in
vitro je ne vois pas quel est l'intérêt
pour notre culture pour notre pays
d'aller sur ces problématiques là la
première c'est que quand on nous dit le
consommateur sera informé belle sornette
comment on va t'en informer le
consommateur qui mangera un plat dans un
restaurant de la quantité qu'il aura à
l'intérieur de cette viande in vitro on
nous dit il faut plus de végétal
savez-vous mess que nous ne produisons
qu'un fruit et un légume sur deux que
nous importons un fruit et un légume sur
deux et que nous sommes incapables par
les injonctions que nous mettons de
développer la culture de légumes et de
fruits qui devraient à vous écouter
faire la base de notre alimentation
alors est-ce que demain nous voulons
traiter le problème du carbone et
importer de plus en plus maintenant si
si ça a été dit tout à l'heure je l'ai
entendu 20% de protéines et 80% de
produits végétal
le deuxième et le troisième élément
c'est ces injonctions contradictoires
l'ultra transformé on lit sans arrêt
dans tous les journaux qu'on lutte
contre l'ultra transformé parce que ça
serait cancérigène et que l'agrobusiness
l'agro-industrie fait des produits ultra
transformés la viande in vitro n'est pas
un produit ultra transformé qu'est-ce
que c'est c'est pas un produit
totalement naturel le quatrième élément
c'est que moi je suis un amoureux des
paysages de la France on n'est pas dans
un pays qui a un désert global on a un
pays qui est multiculturel
d'un point de vue des territoires et des
paysages supprimer l'élevage en France
ça serait supprimé une très grosse
partie des paysages que nous vivons et
nous aurons véritablement des problèmes
là-dessus
trois cinquième élément et j'en termine
là-dessus le savoir-faire le
savoir-faire et le patrimoine culturel
moi je le dis tout net j'ai pas envie de
vivre dans un pays où tout est aseptisé
j'ai pas envie de vivre dans un pays où
on porte un masque de l'eau à longueur
de journée je n'ai pas envie de vivre
dans un pays où on a remplacé les trois
mots de la République française de la
liberté de l'égalité de la fraternité
par la peur la culpabilité et l'interdit
j'ai envie de vivre toujours dans un
pays libre dans lequel j'ai le droit de
manger ce que je veux et en particulier
de la viande de bovin vivant en courant
dans les prés et étant élevé par des
agriculteurs je crois que personne ici
ne tend empêchera